bonjour philippe béchade merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france ce
matin alors cette baisse historique du
jamais vu dans l'histoire pétrolière des
états unis ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que pour ceux
qui détenaient des contrats sur le
pétrole wti pour ça un petit peu
technique je m'en excuse mais on
n'achète pas du pétrole le physique
comme on achète une action dont le cours
est poursuivie toute l'année là on
achète du pétrole par échéances
mensuelles
hélas pour ceux qui détenaient des
contrats d'échéance mais qui expire
aujourd'hui
eh bien il faut livrer ce pétrole et
ceux qui en prennent ce qu'ils
apprennent livraison et bien doivent
pouvoir le stocker quelque part tout
simplement est arrivé à l'échéance
beaucoup d'acheteurs n'ont pas les
capacités de prendre ce ce pétrole de le
de la cheminée de le stocker et donc il
essaie de se débarrasser à tout prix de
ces quantités et on arrive à quelque
chose d'extraordinaire d'art concevable
qui est que pour se débarrasser de ce
pétrole faute de capacités de stockage
et bien les détenteurs des contrats ont
dû payer alors on ne sait pas quelles
contreparties mais payer pour que ce
pétrole soit enlevé absorber et on est
arrivé donc à un moment à une valeur
négative absolument là aussi inouïe sur
réaliste
2 - 40,3 dollars par baril autrement dit
ce qui valait vendredi dernier 18 18 et
demi 18 dollar et demi s'est retrouvé à
-40 et - 37,6 en clôture par contre le
contrat
ce pétrole qui devra être livrée en juin
son cours est resté supérieur à 22
dollars et sur juillet on est même resté
au delà des 27
on rappelle les etats-unis sont le
premier producteur mondial de pétrole
devant l'arabie saoudite
on l'a entendu ce que vous nous dites ça
veut dire qu'il ya une crise de la
demande de stockage les etats-unis ne
sont plus en capacité de stocker
aujourd'hui ce pétrole les conséquences
alors ils sont plus capables de stocker
et c'est un problème très globale c'est
à dire qu'ils n'arrivent plus à stocker
du pétrole qui continuent d'être
acheminés de pays exportateurs du golfe
persique
ils sont du mal également à stocker
celui qui est extrait dans le golfe du
mexique
donc les cuves des raffineries du golfe
du mexique sont pleines celle de
caroline du nord et du sud sont
également plein donc ce pétrole qui
arrive de producteurs étrangers et
maintenant stockés dans des tankers et
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que pour
l'armateur ça devient extrêmement
lucratif
parce que maintenir une cargaison de
pétrole à bord ça coûtait jusqu'à
présent autour de 30 mille dollars par
jour pour une cargaison et en l'espace
de deux week-ends on est passé à 150
mille dollars pour que ce pétrole
restent à bord de toute façon on ne peut
pas le débarquer puisque on a pu les
moyens effectivement de stocker dans les
raffineries
et puis il ya l'autre pétrole qui est
produit en interne qui s'appelle le wti
qui lui les produits essentiellement au
texas
oklahoma et dakota du nord
ce sont des champs pétrolifères vous
savez un petit peu particulier puisqu'il
faut procéder à ce rappel du fracking
c'est de l'extraction
avec injection de fluidifiant de vapeur
on ressort un pétrole qui est assez
liquide assez difficile à raffiner et il
se trouve que justement sur les lieux de
production du nord des états unis
on n'a pas de raffinerie pour traiter ce
pétrole donc on doit l'envoyer soit par
pipeline alors ces pipelines n'existe
pas ou très peu
ou alors on les envoie par camions
citernes il se trouve que tout est plein
les cuves les pipelines et qu'on ne
trouve plus non plus un camion citerne
pour acheminer ce pétrole vers des
raffineries du sud de pays du sud du
pays
donc il n'y a pas d'autres solutions il
faut fermer le robinet ou alors la seule
solution qui aurait pu l'éviter il ya la
catastrophe qu'on a qu'on a constatée et
il avait fallu qu on réinjecte carrément
ce pétrole dans le sol
parce que une fois qu'il est sorti on ne
sait plus quoi en faire ou on le brûle
ou je ne sais pas on ne déverse c'est
une situation incroyable
on n'a plus beaucoup de temps un retour
à la normale vous vous l'envisagez alors
moi je ne suis pas prêt ce spécialiste
du pétrole
mais si les américains enfin si les
producteurs américains continue
d'extraire du pétrole alors non plus
haut à un rythme de 12 millions de
barils jour
mais même s'il descendait à 10 millions
actuellement la demande ne dépasse pas 6
ou 7 millions de barils jour
donc ce que veut dire que le problème
qu'on a eue hier et qu'on a encore
aujourd'hui qui est qui va prendre
livraison de ce pétrole et où est ce
qu'on va le mettre
ce même problème va se reposer donc dans
un mois pour les chaînes en option et se
repose on se reposera également pour le
mois de juillet puisque entre temps le
pétrole produit n'aura pas été consommé
et en termes de capacité de stockage je
crois qu'au stade où on doit être autour
de 82 ou 83 % donc
ou alors on ferme les robinets aux états
unis et on apporte plus un seul baril du
golfe du mexique et du golfe persique
merci alors on aura à nouveau ce
problème à l'échéance juin merci
beaucoup à vous je rappelle que vous
êtes rédacteur en chef
la bourse au quotidien